the West African nation of Mali is
rebuilding having survived a rebellion
by Tuareg Islamist and al-qaeda fighters
with French military help this
poverty-stricken country is struggling
to get back in shape and lay the
foundations for the new state the people
of Mali will be able to vote in
presidential elections planned for July
it's a major political milestone
life goes on calmly enough in Bamako in
the South but the armed threat and the
North has not disappeared so right now
Mali has to painstakingly reconstructed
military from the ground up the European
Union's training mission with its
headquarters in the capital is here to
help the 550 strong a new contingent
will be training the force formed by
abroad and at times volatile mix of
ethnic groups including the Tuareg the
Army's exact size is unknown estimates
vary from five to seven thousand troops
for the European missions commander one
thing is clear a massive task lies ahead
sorry boo devon de sal de la tete de
Caro class punctual Michelle for
Compline mission new projects and a
passive his own since the pesky effects
on efficacy tere naam a set of genomic
it has Suzy key baby
okay magic eBay I think the stock the
chemo for Nieporent on the the copper
humility held the book would be
Yamanouchi usually you Fair Park the
Kidman we killed the wind hostess you
transitive ugly transitive Oh Jane
before perhaps more half of me Pascal a
Tallulah's Whitney is woven in adaptive
condition deformations at a memory a new
condition avoir don't deserve enemy
minion some 60 kilometers northeast of
Bamako teams of European military
trainers will over the next year hope to
totally overhaul is poorly armed
ill-trained and largely rudderless force
the aim of this facility on the
outskirts of the town of kokoro is to
help restore Molly's constitutional and
democratic order while keeping rebels at
bay but in this dusty riverbank camp
where daytime temperatures regularly saw
to 45 degrees Celsius the formidable
challenges that Molly faces also provide
the unique training opportunity for the
armies of Europe EU soldiers are being
forced to learn each other's languages
and military customs they familiarized
themselves with old weapons 2,000 of
these assault rifles were donated to the
Malians by Cyprus they exchange best
practice and share new methods to
Alcatraz important school milky
nationality a complete scam mo certainty
keep the format on a political PU opium
was sampled I am observing company
diff'rently
form a pair ability notic avec this
video - wha
it is Estonia no convenience and
remember keep different nationality and
actual more subjective looted formation
see collision upon activation zone about
in positive communion appended with
naman francais these training teams have
been prepared under extreme time
pressure the mission involves 200
trainers
150 soldiers have the job of protecting
them at a further 200 provide medical
and logistical support and handle
administrative duties Belgian pilots and
nurses are on call and could get to
anyone who's been hurt in half an hour
their air controllers and protection
force for this exercise of French 200
meters away Germans Austrians and
Hungarians are running an impressive
field hospital housed in a warren of
tents on the training bases parade
ground this air-conditioned facility has
beds for eight full-time patients
airlifted in by four giant Antonov
transporter planes some might think this
hospital is too big for any need is
likely to face for the man in charge of
the Medical Center which also has a
mobile pharmacy and a dentist says it's
better to be safe than sorry
if you lightest interfere as of coward
affordability she was all there
a new training mission is here to share
what is better
it was to film it to name as invalid as
palace to Vinny for also harm the
citizen word of the guideline that's via
if as organ see here stated Colonel on
the Moose involution for free nearest
angriff it was memory in valve year
michigan always vang vien very Gaston
actually form the rebuilding of Molly's
army like construction work on the base
has to happen quickly only a reliable
force under civilian control will ensure
that the country can stand alone and
protect its institutions before
international troops withdraw in just
over a month Malian contractors have
transformed these buildings from virtual
ruins into respectable barracks capable
of housing hundreds of troops all this
will be left behind for the training
school the Europeans drawn from 22
nations have about a year to prepare
some two and a half thousand soldiers
beyond the purely military combat
training command and control and
logistics the Marlins will also learn
about the rule of law and who
and rights to help win the trust of
ordinary citizens near the barracks the
first bivouac that will shelter the
malian trainees for the next ten weeks
has been erected living conditions here
a rougher but that there Molly and
Commander says is to be expected no
solace on fair play Forza sedan
confirmes a la formación de quoi se but
early discovery for me
imagine a vu case Isola and Asia I'm Ted
GC same Tillich's ion suit is from eject
II can't over the net agarra down the
mountain to the sea for us lassie would
the military kiln some Sun lock-in some
news from the Superhawk a school of
early also vineyards and the people of
Mali are counting on them the army must
break with the past for confidence to
return the military coos must end the
new force will have to act under
civilian rule and protect the government
as political leaders help this country
through its democratic and
constitutional transition